- [Voiceover] If six is less than
the absolute value of x minus three,
which is less than seven,
and x is equal to zero,
what is one possible value
of the absolute value of x?
So let's just rewrite this
first compound inequality,
then we'll think about this constrained
of x being less than zero.
So they're telling us that six is less
than the absolute value of x minus three,
which is less than seven.
So let's just think about what it means
to take the absolute value.
An absolute value of an expression,
or of a number could be viewed as,
well, how far is that
number away from zero?
For example, we've seen this before,
negative five is five away from zero.
Five is five away from zero.
So if you think about it that way,
now let's draw a number line,
and visualize where
would x minus three sit?
Where are all the possible places
where x minus three could sit?
I'm going to try and draw a pretty big
number line so we can
visualize it reasonably well.
So let's say that this
right over here is zero,
this is positive six,
this is positive seven.
This is negative six,
and this is negative seven.
So if x minus three sits in this interval
between six and seven,
and not equaling those,
because these are not less than or equal,
these are just less than signs.
So if x minus three is in this interval
between six and seven, so if x minus three
is there, then the absolute value
of x minus three is going to be between
six and seven away from zero.
But the other place where
x minus three could be,
is in this interval,
between negative six and negative seven.
X minus three could also be there,
because anything here,
if you take any value
in that interval right over there,
its absolute value,
its distance from zero,
it's between six and seven away from zero.
Notice something over here would be,
so for example, negative 6.2,
that is between six and
seven away from zero.
So this is the absolute value,
this distance to the left,
if we're thinking about this area,
and it's the distance
to the right of zero,
if we're thinking about
things in this interval.
So what are the two situations?
Well, this blue situation is just
six is less than x minus three,
which is less than seven.
We're essentially assuming
that x minus three
is positive, but then there's a case
where x minus three could be negative.
And in that case, we have negative seven,
is going to be less than x minus three,
which is going to be
less than negative six.
So these are the two cases
and to figure out what x would
be in each of these cases,
we could add three to all three parts
of this inequality.
So, if you add three to six,
you get nine is less than...
Add three here, that's the whole point,
the three and the
negative three cancel out,
is less than x, and then,
less than seven plus three is 10.
So that's one possibility.
The other possibility over here,
if you add three to
all the different parts
of this compound inequality,
negative seven plus
three is negative four,
is less than x minus three, plus three,
is x, which is less than negative six
plus three, is negative three.
Now, so, if this was our only constraint,
this is what we would know about x,
that either this is true, or this is true,
but then they tell us another constraint.
They tell us that x is less than...
x is less than zero.
So x can't be greater than nine,
so we can rule out this case,
which pretty much rules out that case,
and makes us focus on this case,
x has to be less than zero.
So what's one possible value
of the absolute value of x?
Well, you can pick any x in this interval
between negative three and negative four.
You could say, well, x could be equal
to negative 3.1, you could say x
is equal to negative 3.01,
you could say x is equal to negative 3.56,
you could say x is equal to negative 3.99.
All of these x's are in this interval,
so one possible value?
Well, we could just say x
is equal to negative 3.5,
you take the absolute value of x,
so then, the absolute value of x
would be equal to positive 3.5,
and we are done.